así es que estás en una florería y
quieres comprar una flor que tenga una
maceta entonces llegas con el dueño de
la tienda de flores y le preguntas qué
tipo de flores venden y él te contesta
aquí vendemos cuatro tipos de flores
tenemos rosas tulipanes girasoles y
lirios y entonces tú le preguntas bueno
y en qué tipo de macetas puedo poner a
estas flores y el dueño de la florería
te contesta cada una de estas flores las
puedes poner en cualquiera de los tres
tipos de macetas que vendemos nosotros
tenemos macetas cafes amarillas y verdes
y entonces la pregunta que yo te hago a
ti
dadas estas circunstancias con cuántas
combinaciones de flores en su maceta
puede salir tuve esa tienda por ejemplo
podría llevarte una rosa en una maceta
café o una rosa en una maceta verde o
tomar una maceta amarilla y ponerle un
girasol o tomar una maceta amarilla y
ponerle un tulipán así es que cuantos
escenarios tenemos cuántos casos con
cuántas flores con su maceta puede salir
de la florería y como siempre te
recomiendo que hagas una pausa y trates
de contestar esta pregunta por tu cuenta
y luego veamos la solución entonces
vamos a ver la solución para no escribir
toda la palabra todo el tiempo lo que
voy a hacer es tomar la letra inicial
entonces puedes tener una maceta café
o una maceta amarilla o una maceta verde
que tienes que tener alguna de estas
tres porque tienes que tener una maceta
y luego para cada una de estas tres
macetas puedes tener cualquiera de los
cuatro tipos de flores que puedes tener
una maceta café con una rosa o puedes
tener una maceta amarilla con una rosa o
una maceta verde con una rosa y de la
misma forma puedes tener una maceta café
con un tulipán o una maceta amarilla con
un tulipán o una maceta verde con un
tulipán o un girasol con una maceta café
un girasol con una maceta amarilla y un
girasol con una maceta verde y
finalmente también puedes tener una
maceta café con un lirio o una maceta
amarilla con un lirio o una maceta verde
con un lirio así es que en total cuántas
opciones tenemos
pues por aquí tenemos tres opciones de
maceta por acá tenemos cuatro opciones
de flores entonces tenemos tres por
cuatro opciones tres tipos de maceta por
cuatro tipos de flores o sea doce
opciones en total y lo podemos ver justo
aquí tenemos una maceta café con una
rosa una maceta café con un tulipán una
maceta café con un girasol una maceta
café con un lirio una maceta amarilla
con una rosa una maceta amarilla con un
tulipán una maceta amarilla con un
girasol una maceta amarilla con un lirio
y bueno así nos seguimos y entonces
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
opciones hay 12 opciones nunca puede
salir de esa florería con 12
combinaciones distintas de flor con
maceta